le soir du 7 juin 2018
on est tous les deux assis à une table
du mais un petit restaurant au coeur de
toulouse
il fait très beau très chaud c'est une
superbe soirée ce soir là je lui ai un
peu tout déballé d'un ça faisait un
moment que j'avais envie de m'investir
dans une démarche éco-responsable plus
qu'en triant quotidiennement mais
déchets ou en arrêtant d'acheter des
vêtements neufs par exemple la vérité
c'est que l'histoire qu'on va vous
raconter ce soir n'a rien
d'extraordinaire
ce n'est pas une histoire incroyable on
était seulement assis tous les deux à la
table de ce restaurant en train de
manger quelque chose de bon et
d'authentiqué et j'avais simplement
besoin de changement et d'action alors
ce soir là j'en ai parlé et il se trouve
que yann ici présent on avait besoin lui
aussi
on avait tous les deux besoin de nous
sentir utile ou du moins plus utile que
là assis à cette table à l'instant t
alors on a discuté d'idées en idées une
question après l'autre on y était ce
soir là on est repartis avec le sourire
le cerveau qui carburait à 10 milles à
l'heure plus motivé que jamais on allait
créer une monnaie locale virtuel et éco
responsable
bonjour à toutes et à tous je vous
présente ces réagir aux je suis vieille
taverne et et on est les deux
cofondateurs de senna on également tous
les deux étudiants à l insat tous et ce
soir on voudrait partager avec vous
notre projet notre aventure pour
commencer voici senna senna dans la
mythologie inuits représente une jeune
femme qui a été maltraité par son mari
puis sacrifié par son père qui l'a jeté
au fond de la mer est la coule au fond
de l'eau et y rester après avoir créé
tous les animaux marins qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
l'histoire raconte que senna est
toujours au fond de la mer dont elle est
la déesse et que lorsque l'eau est
agitée c'est en réalité senna qui est
tourmenté c'est une histoire qui doit
rappeler aux humains question
d'obligation
de traiter les femmes et la mer avec
respect cette histoire nous a beaucoup
touchés avec serena et c'est pour ça on
a décidé de baptiser notre projet en son
honneur scène la maintenance elle n'a
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui on a du mal à se rendre
compte de tout ce qui nous entoure
tenez par exemple cette scène sur
laquelle on marche qu'il a fait
comment combien de temps ça lui a pris
comme un temps ça leur a pris
personnellement je suis incapable de
répondre et je pense que je ne me trompe
pas si je vous dis que je ne suis pas la
seule aujourd'hui tout est transformé
tout vient de très loin d'ailleurs on a
tendance à manger des fruits et légumes
dans le meilleur des cas qui ont parfois
plus voyager que nous dans toute notre
vie on a tendance aussi à consommer plus
que de raison alors que nos placards
débordent déjà deux choses qui ne nous
servent pas après un peu de réflexion
avec yann on a compris que ça ça nous
dérange et on a compris qu'on avait
besoin de revenir à l'essentiel à
l'essence des choses alors naturellement
on s'est demandé comment motiver le plus
de personnes possible à revenir à cet
essentiel pour ça on a pensé à valoriser
l'acte éco citoyens qu'ils représentent
une consommation raisonnée et éthique ou
un investissement dans une association
qui lutte pour la protection de la
planète par exemple pour valoriser ce
geste on avait envie de donner quelque
chose aux gens qui soient utiles qui
leur permettent de poursuivre leur élan
et d'agir encore plus par la suite au
début donc on a pensé à des points puis
progressivement ces points sont devenus
monnaies puis monnaies locales et c'est
ainsi que le cid est né un peu long le
petit bonhomme que vous voyez edgar à
chaque fois quel gars agir ou consomment
de la le réseau d'enseignés éthique
local et durable que celle là englobe il
gagne 2,6 quelques mutants qui cumule
ensuite sur son compte celle là pour ça
on a fait développer une application
smartphone par deux étudiants de l'insee
à d'ailleurs aussi et c'est cette
application qui permet la gestion
complète des sites grâce à l'application
edgar
il peut collecter des saisies en
agissant pour la planète il peut les
partager avec ses proches et il peut
également les réutiliser comme une vraie
monnaie au sein des enseignes du réseau
sainement quand on a pensé à ce concept
là on s'est demandé au tout début
si on était les seuls naturellement
alors on s'est renseigné on a eu pas mal
de bouquins et on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait rien inventé en fait est que
des initiatives de monnaies locales il
en existait plein à travers le monde
avec serena on en a sélectionné deux
trois exemples pour vous montrer à quoi
ces initiatives pouvait ressembler pour
commencer il y allie porte monnaie c'est
un système qui a été développé dans 12
villes de la région du limbourg en
belgique
le principe c'est que tous les habitants
de ces villes qui adopte des
comportements respectueux de la planète
gagne des points qui peuvent ensuite
réutilisés pour acheter des produits
durables
aujourd'hui le système qui compte un
petit peu plus de dix mille utilisateurs
à travers ces douze villes de la région
de l'amour ensuite il y à l'anus par pas
ce qui est une monnaie qui a été en
circulation dans la ville de rotterdam
en 2002 les participants en cumul des
unités sur une carte de fidélité
puis le vent suite réutiliser ces unités
dans le réseau de muespach passe pour se
procurer des produits ou des services et
peuvent aussi profiter de services
municipaux comme par exemple les
transports publics ou pour participer à
certains événements entre 2002 et 2003
plus de dix mille cartes de fidélité
avait été émise avant que de nouvelles
élections municipales ne marque
malheureusement la fin du projet le nude
spar passe héliporté money se rapproche
donc du fonctionnement du site car ils
viennent valoriser l'acte éco
responsable la différence c'est que le
site se trouve sur le smartphone enfin
voici le sol violette la monnaie locale
de notre jolie ville rose qui est donc
en circulation à toulouse depuis 2011
son fonctionnement est complexe
on pourrait passer des heures à
l'expliquer mais en résumé on
échange d euros contre des sols puis on
utilise les sols pour payer chez un
certain nombre de prestataires
toulousain pour nous c'était important
de créer quelque chose qui soit
complémentaire avec ce qui existe déjà
alors on a décidé de travailler avec le
sol en récompensant les paiements en sol
avec décide pour apporter notre petite
pierre notre contribution à cet édifice
des monnaies locales qui est déjà très
bien construit on a donc voulu créer un
système qui regroupe toutes les belles
initiatives déjà existantes et les
connectent en faisant couler décide
entre elles quand on constitue le réseau
cnla avec serena en fonction des vals
que l'on porte
on s'attache beaucoup à la proximité des
produits et des services proposés
les enseignes que l'on fait intégré au
réseau ont des valeurs communes partage
des points communs qui sont de manière
générale le renforcement d'une économie
locale
le renforcement d'une production et
d'une consommation plus éthique et
raisonnée et une réduction de nos
impacts environnementaux avec serena on
a remarqué que ces critères sont une
conséquence de ce conte de ce que l'on
obtient quand on se concentre sur des
circuits courts la proximité des valeurs
éthiques local et durable et c'est ça
qu'on a envie de mettre en valeur grâce
au projet permet toutes les personnes
qui ont eu la chance de rencontrer
vraiment quand on a constitué le réseau
je pense notamment à des commerçants ou
à des membres d'associations on a
retrouvé des valeurs d'entraidé de
partage et de simplicité et je dirais
même de gentillesse ce sont des
personnes qui savent d'où viennent leurs
produits qui connaissent la qualité des
services qu'ils proposent pour un
commerçant par exemple la personne va
quasiment à chaque fois chercher ce dont
elle a besoin en main propre sur le
producteur et c'est ce genre de choses
qui sont importantes et qu'on aime et
qu'on aimerait bien valorisé quand son
projet
de plus toutes ces rencontres ont
vraiment forgé notre parcours
d'entrepreneur et rien que pour ça ça
vaut le coup d'entreprendre en vous
disant ça je pense à une commerçante qui
m'a prise dans ses bras quand je suis
reparti après lui avoir expliqué ce
qu'on voulait faire avec le projet je
pense aussi à la manière qu'elle a de
servir ses clients
elle prend le temps elle explique elle
questionne grâce à elle grâce à eux
en général on a compris qu'il pouvait
exister un lien entre un commerçant ou
un membre d'association d'une part et un
client d'autre part cette betterhomes
oui je suis allé la chercher chez un
producteur qui possède un maraîcher près
de montauban
elle a l'air un peu fatigué comme ça
mais je vous jure que le goût est à
tomber par terre
est ce que vous voulez goûter bon vous
savez quoi on va faire plus simple je
vous l'offre
mais c'est vraiment parce que c'est vous
jour après jour rencontre après
rencontre on s'est indigné que ce lien
se soit perdu aujourd'hui on fait nos
courses dans les grandes surfaces près
c'est entre deux heures de cours ou en
sortant du travail
en résumé on est bien loin de la
betterave de montauban toutes ces
monnaies alternatives et locales dont
celle là fait partie ont pour objectif
de remédier à cette aberration sel dans
ces années vous parle en recréant
souvient qui se perd aujourd'hui
et petit à petit en redirigeant
l'économie vers des enseignes qui ont du
sens pour nous pour la planète et pour
vous on l'espère nous dans le projet
quand on essaie de développer on s'est
essentiellement concentrée sur le fait
de motiver un maximum de personnes à
adopter des comportements éco
responsables des comportements
respectueux de la planète pour
construire tout ça on s'est posé
beaucoup
beaucoup de questions et notamment des
questions sur ce qu'on pouvait apporter
aux autres ce qu'on était capable de
leur apporter pour aider notre question
principale avec sa reine avec serena
c'était et c'est toujours d'ailleurs
de quoi avons nous besoin
personnellement pour changer nos
comportements de manière durable
on essaie d'y répondre tout d'abord on
s'est dit qu'on avait besoin de temps
qu'ils n'ont pas de temps aujourd'hui en
recherchant des alternatives plus
durable dans tous les domaines on espère
donc réussir à nous faire gagner un
petit peu de temps en recherchant par
exemple des épiceries locales qui
proposent des produits en vrac ou des
magasins de vêtements du seconde ou des
associations qui proposent des ateliers
ludiques pour réaliser sa propre lessive
on recherche tous à en amour pour
espérer nous faire gagner du temps
ensuite on voulait aussi apporté un
petit coup de pouce financier parce
qu'on a conscience que de consommer
mieux ça coûte souvent plus cher et on
voulait vraiment minimiser ce frein
alors pour remédier à ce problème
on essaye de valoriser chaque
consommation éco responsable avec des
signes qui rappelons le possède une
vraie valeur financière
on veut également constituer une
communauté qui permettent aux gens de
partager leurs expériences et leurs
sites
au passage le but c'est de créer une
émulation autour de cette collecte de
sites que les gens se sentent poussés
par la force de la communauté qu'elle
rencontre des personnes qui soient
motrice pour elle et qui les incite à
s'investir et à essayer de nouvelles
alternatives
le but c'est vraiment est tout
simplement de rassembler les gens autour
d'un sujet qui leur tient à coeur
et finalement on voulait renforcer et on
veut renforcer le côté humain celui qui
fait que les gens iront à la rencontre
des commerçants proximité et des
associations
on sait que le gain de 6 il nécessite
une rencontre physique entre la personne
et le professionnel et ça c'est très
important pour nous parce que ça engage
un échange s'est engagé une discussion
une discussion
autour des produits du commerçant autour
des pratiques de l'association
toutes les personnes qu'on a rencontrés
ont adoré nous parler de leur métier
donc si un jour vous avez l'occasion de
les rencontrer mais ce n'était pas leur
poser plein de questions
et cette discussion elle est bénéfique
parce qu en quelque sorte
elle sensibilise et la sensibilisation
c'est la première étape pour arriver à
une prise de conscience en parlant de
prise de conscience
il est assez grisant de se dire
qu'apparemment c'est de notre proximité
trop importante avec certaines espèces
animales qu'est née la plus grande
pandémie que nous humains du xxème et
xxième siècle ayant jamais connu
pandémie qui nous a peu à peu voler nos
libertés une relation et notre proximité
comme pour nous rappeler d'où elle
venait
c'est vrai qu'on n'avait pas du tout
pensé au départ quand on a essayé de
créer ce projet mais on espère vraiment
que ce concept
il va permettre aux gens de créer du
lien et de se rassembler malgré le
contexte qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pour finir on aimerait vous dire quelque
chose avec ian quelque chose qui est
très important pour nous on aimerait
vous dire que tous les deux on a de la
chance je vous assure qu'on a beaucoup
beaucoup de chance déjà on a la chance
d'être né dans un pays développé
on a la chance d'avoir reçu une
éducation et de n'avoir jamais manqué de
rien on a la chance d'avoir toujours été
soutenu par nos proches de manière
inconditionnelle et d'avoir des amis
incroyable on a la chance aussi de
s'être retrouvés tous les deux tout ça
fait qu'au fil du temps on a pu acquérir
une conscience écologique
pourquoi parce que notre objectif
principal dans la vie n'était pas de
survivre comme c'est l'objectif de
milliards de personnes sur notre planète
aujourd'hui tous ces conditions réunies
nous ont donc offert
ou du moins facilité le pouvoir d'agir
il y a tant de choses à améliorer tant
d'inégalités
alors tous ceux qui nous écoutent tous
ceux qui pensent comme nous tous ceux
qui sont dans notre cas sachez qu'on
vous attend
sachez que le monde entier vous attend
et qu'il a besoin de vous une fois que
vous aurez décidé d'agir accrochez vous
y fort et ne lâchait pas pour rien au
monde vraiment cette notion de
s'accrocher à ce qu'on fait elle nous
parle beaucoup avec serena pendant le
projet on a eu plein de moments de doute
où on s'est posé des questions est-ce
que ce qu'on fait c'est bien est-ce que
ça va plaire aux gens est-ce que ça va
être utile pour les autres
et bien c'est dans ces moments là bien
précis que vos retours sont très
importants pour nous mais pour le projet
surtout je repense notamment à une
discussion que j'ai eue avec 1 mde sur
le campus de lisa qui me disait que le
projet lui a permis de s'investir que ça
avait une petite étincelle pour lui qui
avait permis de trouver la force de
changer son comportement que les
anciennes proposé de plaider que les
associations ne plaisait que le principe
lui plaisait et il m'a remercié pour ça
ce genre de paroles qui sont peut-être
anodine pour vous nous touche énormément
avec serena ce sont des paroles fortes
qui nous apporte un regain d'énergie et
de motivation qui nous entraînent
beaucoup plus loin et qui entraîne de
manière générale tous les porteurs de
projets beaucoup plus long donc quand
vous aurez l'occasion de dire à
quelqu'un que vous aimez ce qu'il ou
elle fait ne la manquez pas ça peut lui
apporter
cette petite touche d'espoir et surtout
ça peut avoir beaucoup plus d'impact que
ce que vous pensez nous
grâce à tout ça grâce à vous tous on a
décidé de s'accrocher et le mercredi 3
mars 2021
les premiers sites ont été distribués
merci merci